(whooshing)
- [Man] Lift off, lift off.
(instrumental music)
- [Narrator] Meet Bjarke.
Basically, he's a tinkerer,
and he and his colleagues
have cobbled together
this simple let of sensors
that will help these kids.
- I'm Angelique Swartz.
- Tara Sadat.
- Rabelani Nenungwi.
- [Narrator] Get a lot closer to space.
That's possible because well,
Bjarke, you tell ‘em.
Okay, so here's how it works.
The students get their hands on Bjarke's
XinaBox sensors, those ones,
which give real time
readings on things like
temperature, humidity,
and UV light levels.
Then, they're built
into Bjarke's satellite,
which is loaded on to a rocket, like this,
and then, they're sent
into lower Earth orbit.
- [Man] We have stage one separation.
- [Narrator] Cool, right?
- Pretty cool.
These little things are
just gonna be in space
recording everything we don't know about.
What is it like up there
where we've never been before
and it's really cool because
we will get to see that.
- [Narrator] So, just like that,
a bunch of kids in South
Africa will be operating
their own classroom ground control,
playing with data taken
straight from outer space.
(instrumental music)
And that's all part of Bjarke's plan.
Huh, that's clever.
Wonder if it's working.
- Thinking of doing medicine.
- Plan on studying for
about, uh, seven to 12 years
to become a neurologist.
- One day I would actually
want to work with these things
because they are just so interesting.
Technology and math and
science and engineering
has made all of what we are now possible,
and that's why it's important.
(instrumental music)